all right guys we're gonna talk about the prostate
there's a lot of false information about prostate
number one this this theory out there that they
say that too much testosterone especially the
most powerful type of testosterone which is DHT
causes in a large prostate well if that was true
then why is it that the certain doctors use DHT
as a therapy to shrink the prostate it's not true
that too much prostate have too much testosterone
causes enlargement of the prostate simply because
as you age testosterone goes down so why would
you have an enlarged prostate if you get older
it's basically the estrogen testosterone and
estrogen work together when you lower testosterone
you raise estrogen estrogen is an anabolic hormone
it makes things enlarged in a female it will make
a fibroid tumor okay and a male body enlarge the
prostate so if you have prostate enlargement it's
because you have too much estrogen now where does
estrogen come from well first of all your body can
make it or it can come from the foods that you
eat the glands that make estrogen in a male body
are the adrenal glands so there's also your own
fat can make estrogen so the fatter you are the
more estrogen you can have and so we must reduce
estrogen okay a couple ways to do it is avoid
food that has estrogen in it you have hormone free
meets all the GMO foods genetically modified soy
corn beet sugar that are in the grocery store that
are not labeled they are very estrogenic because
they're loaded with a pesticide that mimics
estrogen so unless you're doing organic food
you're getting a lot of GMO food which is then
going to increase estrogen amounts now estrogen
it causes cancer it causes prostate cancer that
causes cancer of the cervix and females and breast
tissue and thyroid cancer it's pretty nasty so
luckily there are foods that naturally detoxify
things that turn into cancer and estrogen itself
and it's called cruciferous foods that would be
like the kale that broccoli or the brussel sprouts
the cabbage the radish arugula you need to start
eating those okay if you have a hard time eating
those do regular vegetables and you can enhance
it with like a cruciferous concentrate okay
you can use that as well and this has all the
cruciferous with some other ones but if you have
a prostate problem I'll go take probably six of
these a day okay so that's one thing you can do
the other thing you can do is take seek help in
the morning take one one tablet seek help will
also reduce estrogen it's really good for the
thyroid too and it's good for if you have cold
feet okay so number two or reduce aroma taste
what is a Roma taste that is an enzyme that's made
by your body that converts the testosterone that
you have left in estrogen great so that's that's
nothing that's happening to is that we're actually
converting testosterone and making your body's are
making more estrogen that's crazy so having a lot
of estrogen is very carcinogenic it's it's going
to increase your risk factors for cancer so there
are even medications that are aromatase inhibitors
okay to fix cancer or to kill cancer but you want
to use the natural things that are aroma taste
inhibitors and the best one that I know of is
stinging nettle root stinging nettle root is an
a great plant or a root that you can get as a
tablet form and you want to actually double the
dosage it's great also as an anti-inflammatory
it's great to prevent hair loss so this is like an
awesome thing for the prostate consider it better
than some of the saw palmetto stuff that you would
get in some supplements but if you have prostate
this is the one you need to get and you'll start
noticing something like it changes okay if you
get up to pee at night that should improve with
the insulin correction as well because that's
really a one of the side effects from insulin
is excessive urination at night so as you fix
the blood sugars you also pee less so it may come
from prostate enlargement or it could come from
the blood sugar issues okay hope this helped
apply it and I will see you in the next video